مع استمرار الاتهامات المتبادله بخرق
الهدن المعلنه الجيش السوداني يعلن
موافقته على تمديد الهدنه الحاليه 72 ساعه
اضافيه ابتداء من منتصف الليله وفي مقابله
مع الجزيره المتحدث الاقليمي باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول ان لدى واشنطن
اليات للضغط على الاطراف كالعقوبات والبيت
الابيض يقول انه يستبعد تحسن الاوضاع
وبعد تقديم الايجاد مبادره لتهدئه والحوار
مواقف ضبابيه من التفاوض بيان للجيش يعلن
موافقه مبدئيا من البرهان على المبادره
والخارجيه تنفي قبول الجيش الحوار مع
الدعم السريع وفي تصريح للجزيره المستشار
السياسي لحميتي يرهن الدخول في المفاوضات
بوجود ما سماه مبادره حقيقيه
مخاوف دوليه من نقص امدادات السلع
الاساسيه في السودان مسؤول في اليونيسيف
يطالب بتوجيه مساعدات دوليه عاجله مدير
الهلال والصليب الاحمر الدولي في الخرطوم
يتحدث للجزيره عن حاجه ماسه لايصال
المعونات ومع استمرار موجات الفرار من
المواجهات توقعات امميه بتجاوز عدد
اللاجئين الى الجوار اكثر من 200 الف اذا
استمر القتال
[موسيقى]
اذا بعد نحو ساعه كان من المفترض ان تنتهي
الهدنه التي اعلنت في السودان لكن بيانا
للجيش اقر موافقه على تمديد 72 ساعه اخرى
ماربا عن امل الجيش السوداني بالتزام من
سماهم المتمردين بمتطلبات سرايان الهدنه
وعدم خرقها اعلان الجيش لم يقابله حتى
اللحظه اعلان من قوات الدعم السريع
معنى من الخرطوم مراسله الجزيره هيثم اويت
ومن ام درمان مراسل الجزيره حسن رزاق
ونبدا معك هيثم هل من مؤشرات تدل على ان
السودان سيدخل هدنه خامسه بعد ساعه من
الان وستنفذ بالحد الادنى على الاقل
حسن نعم حاله من الهدوءه الان تسيطر على
مشهد الحياه هنا في وسط الخرطوم وفي
العديد من مناطق الخرطوم الاخرى بعد يوم
ساخب من المواجهات ومن
الخروقات التي صاحبت الهدنه الاخيره نحن
نمضي بعد اقل من ساعتين من الان لهدنه
جديده هي الهدنه الخامسه في تاريخ هذه
المواجهات الامان المعقوده على ان تكون
هذه الهدنه هذه المره يعني تجد القبول
وتجد الالتزام من الطرفين من اجل اتاحه
فرصه لتحقيق المقاصد من هذه الهدنه والتي
تتمثل في اتاحه فرصه لتحسين الاوضاع
الانسانيه المترديه وكذلك اتاحت فرصه
لخروج العالقين من
ممثلي البعثات الدبلوماسيه والرعايه الدول
الاجانب الذين ما زالوا يتوافدون او
يغادرون الخرطوم الى بلدانهم هذه الهدنه
تاتي وسط مناشدات عديده وتكثيف اتصالات من
قبل كل الجهات سواء كانت على المست
والمحلي او العالمي بضروره حسن الاطراف
على الاستفاده من هذه الهدنه لجعلها مدخلا
لتحقيق يعني سلام واستقرار انتظره
سودانيون منذ بدايه هذه الاحداث المؤشرات
ربما تكون موجوده والاعمال ما زالت معقوده
على ان تكون هذه الهدنه يعني قائمه ولكن
اصوات الرصاص التي تنطلق من حين الى اخر
هي التي تخترق جدار صمت هذه الهدن دائما
وهي التي تمثل تحديا كبيرا لاستمرار وصمود
هذه الهدن وفق اي اسس ومبادرات ستكون هذه
الهدنه الخامسه التي اعلن الجيش الالتزام
بها الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه اضافيه
الجيش في بيانه قال هذه الهدنه جاءت بعد
اتصالات مكثفه من الجانب السعودي
والامريكي الذين يعني سعياء وصلاه صلاتهما
بالطرفين من اجل ضروره اتاحه هذه الهدنه
واتاحه فرصه للتحقيق قدر من خفض التصعيد
وبالتالي هذه الهدنه بحسب بيان الجيش جادي
استجابه لهذه الجهود المبذوله من قبل
الدولتين الولايات المتحده والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا هناك جهود من
منظمه الايجاده التي تواصل مساعيها من اجل
ايضا حصل اطراف وحملهم على ضروره القبول
بهدنه جديده وبلا الدخول في مفاوضات يعني
بين طرفين لايجاد حل نهائي لهذه الازمه
ولكن حتى الان لم تتبلور الثقه والصوره
النهائيه لهذه المفاوضات التي لم يعني
يبرز الطرفان حتى الان الجيش كان قد وافق
مبدئيا من خلال بيان ولكن جاء بيان اخر
للخارجيه
التزام الجيش او دخول الجيش باي في اي
مفاوضات ولكن ما زالت الجهود والاتصالات
جاريه سواء كان من الايجارات او من
الاتحاد الافريقي حول هذا الموضوع طيب
يبقى طبعا تساؤل مشروع حول موقف الدعم
السريع من هذه الهدنه هل صدر اي موقف او
حتى من بعض مصادر الدعم السريع بالنسبه
للهدنه الخامسه باختصار هيثم
رسميا لم يصدر موقف ولكن المستشار السياسي
للدعم السريع لقائد الدعم السريع في حوار
مع الجزيره في وقت سابق اليوم قال بانه
منفتحون لكافه
الهدن او لكافه المبادرات المطروحه سواء
كانت المبادره
من جنوب السودان مبادره الايجارات
المبادره الثلاثيه والرباعيه كل المبادرات
المطروحه الان هم منفتحون لها ويدرسون هذه
المبادرات وسيقومون بالرد عليها حسب
تعبيره في ضوء هذه الهدى وبانتظار الهدنه
الخامسه نطلع من حسن رزاق على الوضع
الميداني في الخرطوم في ام درمان تحديدا
حيث تتواجد حسنا
حسنا لم اسمع السؤال
الوضع الميداني عموما كيف هو
الهدوء هو حاليا سيد الموقف في منطقه ام
درمان طوال الساعتين الماضيتين لم نسمع
ذوي اي طلقات او مضادات للطائرات او قذائب
او حتى تحليق جوي لطائرات سلاح الجو
السوداني والتي كانت طوال النهار وحتى قبل
اكثر من ثلاث ساعات تحلق في سماء ام درمان
تحديدا في المناطق التي نحن نتواجد فيها
في منطقه جنوب ام درمان
لكن على اي حال حسن التداعيات الانسانيه
لمدينه ام درمان سيما ان الاشتباكات
الجويه هي السائده وهي طبيعه هذا
الاشتباكات على عكس الاشتباكات على الارض
في الخرطوم طبعا كلما انتجهنا شمالا كلما
كانت اثار المعارك او اثار الاشتباكات هي
تقل باعتبار المناطق شمال ام درمان هي
نسبيا مستقره اكثر على عكس المناطق
انقطع التواصل
مع حسن رزاق من ام درمان على كل نشكره
جزيل الشكر ونشكر هيثم اويت من الخرطوم
ونشير الى موافقه الدعم السريع على الهدنه
التي كنا نتحدث عنها وهي الهدنه
الخامسه في خبر عاجل الدعم السريع يعلن
موافقته على تمديد هذه الهدنه
لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه اضافيه بعدما كان
الجيش ايضا قد اعلن موافقته على تمديد هذه
الهدنه
امريكيا قال البيت الابيض انه يستبعد ايه
تحسن للوضع في السودان وان الاداره
الامريكيه تحث مواطنيها على المغادره خلال
اليومين القادمين وكان المتحدث الاقليمي
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه صمو البربورغ قد
قال في مقابله مع الجزيره ان بلاده لديها
ادوات للضغط على طرفي الصراع لكن الاهم هو
وجود صوت موحد من قبل المجتمع الدولي لفرض
وقت لاطلاق النار
لدينا بعض الادوات واريات مثل الاقوبات او
تصنيف بعض الكائنات في لاهره لدينا هذه
الادوات واليات احداث جانب ولكن اهم واقوى
من كل ذلك او من اي ضغط يمارسها اي بلد او
يمارسه اي بلد بنفسه الاهم شيء الصوت
الموحد الصوت الموحد الرساله الموحده بين
كل دور بين كل الدول وكل من كل انهاء
العالم من المجتمع الدولي من الولايات
المتحده الامم المتحده دوله اوروبيه
الدوله الخليجيه رساله واضحه للاطراف
اطلاق النار
من الخرطوم ينضمون الينا الهندي عز الدين
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بك سيد
الهندي يعني من الاخر البيت الابيض يستبعد
اي تحسن للوضع في السودان في الفتره
المقبله ويحس الامريكيين على المغادره
خلال اليومين المقبلين هل هذا يعني بان كل
هذه الهدى التي يتم اعلانها او يتفق عليها
في النهايه هدفها تامين عمليات الاجلاء لا
اكثر ولا اقل
مرحبا بك وبمشاهدين الجزيره وباهلنا في
السودان انا بفتكر كما قلت انت قبل قليل
بالضغط هذه الهدن يبدو ان هدف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه منها هو
رعاياها بعد ان اجلت دبلوماسيه يعني
بالايام الاولى تم ايداع نحو 100 دبلوماسي
موظف في السفاره الامريكيه عبر عمليه
انزال لمروحيات عسكريه في فضاء المحيط
بالسفاره الامريكيه في السوبر حيث تعتبر
من اكبر السفارات مساحه في افريقيا تم
اجلاء البعثه الدبلوماسيه جميعها الى خارج
السودان الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الان
يريدون ان يجروا رعاياهم من اصحاب
الجنسيات المزدوجه طبعا هنالك عشرات
الالاف من السوداني من حمله الجنسيات
الامريكيه البريطانيه وبالتالي الان
المرحله لايجار لانه في النهايه مواطنين
امريكا انا اعتذر انه هذه
هذه الهدن
غير يعني ما عندها غايات سياسيه ما عندها
اهداف استراتيجيه الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع بيوافقوا هدنه بعد هدنه ولكن حقيقه
على الارض لا يوجد هدنه هنالك عمليات
تحشيش من الدعم السريع يحاول ان يستقوي
بقواته في الولايات خاصه من ناحيه الغرب
كردفان كلما فرصه توفرت له معلومات عن
حركه مركبات عسكريه قادمه
يسارع الى ضربها بالطيران
ولذلك انا اعتبر
هذه الهدن والموافقه عليها هذه الغده
الخامسه
يقرر حاله اللاحم واللا سلك
وهل اساسا يعني حتى حاله الحرب هل هل يمكن
لحاله الحرب ان تحسم
انا اعتقد انه حتى الان طبعا الجيش
السوداني
نفذ ضربات قويه جدا على معسكرات الدعم
السريع في كل المواقع حول العصر الان
الدعم السريع لا يتحرك من معسكر محدد من
ناحيه كسر عظم هذا الجيش الدعم السريع
مليش الدعم السريع تم كسر القوه الاساسيه
له مركبات الاف المركبات
احترقت الاف الجثث كانت في الشوارع وفي
المعسكرات ثم التصويرها وتوزيعها عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وحتى عبر
الوكالات الانباء والقنوات الفضائيه ولكن
بصوره اساسيه وذلك معركه مطلوب من الجيش
حسبها سريعا هي معركه وسط الخرطوم محيط
القصر الجمهوري محيط المطار محيط القياده
لانه لا زالت اولشات هذه في هذه المناطق
وهذا هو اليوم الثالث عشر استمرار هذه
الحرب بهذا التطاول يؤدي الى استمرار
الازمه الانسانيه مثلا في مدينه بحري
13 يوم الان مواطنوا بحري بلميات لانه
قوات الدعم السريع
نعم يعني كل كل هذه عفوا كل كل هذه
التداعيات يتم تغطيتها واصبحت واصبحت
واضحه للجميع ولكن
عمليا على ارض الواقع يعني عندما تتحدث
انه على الجيش ان يحسم المعركه في الخرطوم
قرب القياده العامه والقصر الجمهوري لماذا
لو لم يستطع حسم هذه المعركه ارجوك
باختصار
طبعا
المشكله ان قوات الدعم الس
ريع كافيه داخلها تتحصن بها كانت هناك قوه
موجوده لحراسه القصر الجمهوري لانه قائد
الدعم السريع هو شخصيه الدستوريه الثانيه
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده مكتبه في القسوه
الجمهوري كانت هنالك قوات حراسه موجوده
داخل القصر الجمهوري مشاركه لقوات الجيش
لا اعرف يعني ملابسات خروج قوات الجيش او
كيف سيطرت قوات الدعم السريع على القصر
الجمهوري مع انه المفروض ان هناك قوات جيش
موجوده في القسوه الجمهوري في مجلس
الوزراء في محيط وزاره الداخليه انا
حسم معركه وسط الخرطوم هو اساسي لتاكيد
نهايه هذه المعركه او اعتقال قائد الدعم
السريع اما هذا او هذا طبعا
دعم السريع بادر بعمل عسكريه لاعتقاد
البدايه كانت بضرب انزل عبد الفتاح اما
الاعتقال اما الاعتقال
وحزقه حسم المعركه عسكريا بشكل او باخر
لكن يبقى سؤال الذي لم تجب عليه ماذا لو
لم يستطع الجيش حسن المعركه وهنا يبقى
سؤالا كبيرا شكرا لك الهندي عز الدين
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من الخرطوم
وننتقل الى البسط تطبيق ايضا من الخرطوم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي سيد طبيق لماذا
دائما
يتاخر الدعم السريع في موافقته على الهدن
التي تعلن ويكون الجيش هو السباق
بالموافقه والاعلان عنها ما السبب
لك تحيه لمشاهدي قناه الجزيره والتحيه
طيبه
هذا الامر
يتعلق يعني بيانات مواد الدعم السريع يعني
وهذه
الهدن لكن على حسب علمي وحسب قراءه النواه
الدعم السريع لا ترفض
طلبت منها وهي ملتزمه
لكن
على هذه
يعني يتم تاخير لكن
ما فرح
بهذه الدعم
يرحبون باي مبادره وانهم موافقين على على
تطلب يعني منهم من اي مبادره من الداخل
ولكن يعني حتى المسلحه التي تبادل بهذه
يعني المدن انا يعني ارى واشاهد ان هنالك
ليس ليس يوجد واضح بهذه يعني وقبل قليل
كانت تعلق الطائرات يعني في سماع في سماع
يعني الطائرات الحربيه كما يعني
البعض السيد الباشا نعم البعض يرجع
عدم الموافقه السريعه او عدم الاستجابه
السريعه وحتى عدم صدور موقف واضح من الدعم
السريع هو فقدان القياده المركزيه لانه
ليست هناك قياده مركزيه يتشتت القرار
وبالتالي
يصعب اتخاذ قرار موحد الا بعد حين من قبل
الدعم السريع ما رايكم
[موسيقى]
السيطره وقد تمت
بقيت يعني تنظيف هذا حبيبي
يشاهدون هذا المواطن السوداني موجوده في
داخل الخرطوم في القياده العامه وفي القصر
الجمهوري وجنوب جنوب في المطار وجنوب
الخرطوم وفي شرق النيل وفي موجود
هذه المقابره
وهذا حديث
للحقيقه تماما نحن ما نريد الان الالتزام
بهذه الهدل وتطويره الى وقت
وايجاد حل حل امثل يعني للخروج من هذا
المازق وانهاء هذه الحرم الذي يعني تدور
الان في الخرطوم اي كلام غير ذلك هو مجادل
وهي مغامره
على النار ونحن الان يعني
لا يمنع انه طالب
هذه الهدى فضيله
والرجوع
والعقل كما مررنا وذكرنا يعني مرارا عبر
هذه القناه لان هذه الحربيه الخاتم الاول
هو الوطن والحاضر الاول والذي يعاني الان
الى هذه الحرب والمواطن السوداني شكرا لك
الباشا تطبيق الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من
الخرطوم
خلال ساعه الهنا الماضيه كانت هناك الكثير
من التطورات على الارض نتابع ذلك في العرض
التالي
قبل ساعات من دخول الهدنه الخامسه حيز
التنفيذ في السودان بقيت العاصمه الخرطوم
بمدنها الثلاث عنوان المعارك التي تحولت
الى حرب شوارع في الخرطوم بحري قالت قوه
الدعم السريع ان الجيش قصف نقاطه مركزها
في ضاحيه كافوري ومحيط المنطقه الصناعيه
شرقيه المدينه غير بعيد من هناك كان محيط
القصر الجمهوري مسرح اشتباكات المتقطعه
بين الطرفين وشهدت اعمده دخان تتصاعد وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم تحديدا قرب جسر الماكنيمر
احد ثلاثه جسور واصله بين الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري هكذا تبدو العاصمه مسرح
العمليات ومحاولات السيطره بين الطرفين
خصوصا محيط القصر الجمهوري مع الضغط
المتواصل على المنطقه من المحاور الشماليه
للعاصمه يقول الجيش السوداني نقوات الدعم
السريع ما زالت تقصف مناطق وسط الخرطوم
بشكل عشوائي رغم تاكيد الجيش ان وضع
العاصمه مستقر جدا باستثناء ولايه غرب
دارفور هناك على الحدود السود التشاديه
حيث مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
التي كانت على موعد مع هجمات للدعم السريع
على مقر حكومه الولايه
[موسيقى]
وبالحديث عن المعارك فاقد رصد مراسل
الجزيره محمد الطيب اثار القصف الذي تعرض
له عدد من المنازل في منطقه الكلاكله جنوب
غرب العاصمه الخرطوم قبل ايام
نحن الان في المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه من
الخرطوم العاصمه وبالتحديد في منطقه
الكلاكله القبه عموما هذه المناطق هي
بعيده من العمليات العسكريه نوعا ما وليست
فيها عمليات متاخمه
في هذه المنطقه لكن لكنها تعرضت للقصد
تلاحظون الان خلفي هذه واحد من المنازل
التي تدمرت
بالكامل بفعل القصف هذه البيوت اغلب هذه
المناطق البيوت التي فيها هي بيوت شعبيه
وليست فيها نوعيه الخرسانه التي تبنى بها
البيوت الحديثه يعني نوعيه البيوت تبنى من
الطوب ومن الطين كما تلاحظون حتى ان سقفها
وسقف بسيط وليس من الخرسانه
والاسمنت وهذه البيوت تعرضت لقصف هذا
المنزل تعرض اهله للقصف عدد كما عرفنا من
اهل المنطقه انهم الان يتداون يتداون
ويستشفون في المستشفى القريب هنا في هذه
المنطقه نوعا ما الحركه والمستشفيات جزء
من المستشفيات يعمل
حسب ما عرفنا ان هناك ثلاثه عشر منزلا
تعرض
للقصف او انه تضرر بفعل القصف في هذه
المنطقه نتيجه الاشتباكات الدائره ما بين
قوات الدعم السريع وما بين الجيش السوداني
الاحياء هنا ما زال الهلع يسيطر على سكان
هذه المنطقه الذين التقينا بهم نلاحظ في
الشاشه الان ان عدد من سكان هذه المنطقه
يتضافرون في الجهود لترميم اثار القذف
التي لحقت بالسوري منزلهم ويعملون في
المحاوله
[موسيقى]
اعاده البناء لهذا الصوره التي تطرف القصف
من الناحيه الاخرى هذا هذا المنزل نزل
برمته على العدو سوي بالارض سنحاول ان
ندخل هذا المنزل الذي تضرر جزئيا بسبب
القصف في هذه المنطقه ونلتقي باهله لنعرف
ما الذي جرى بالنسبه لهم هذا هو رب هذه
الاسره
تعرض ما زالت الامور بالنسبه له هو يعني
هناك اثار ومتضرر يعني هل لنا هل صحتك
جيده تعرضت في بعض ما زالت يعني هناك اثار
القصف والاجزاء والجروح التي ما زلت
تتداوى بها يعني ما الذي جرى لك والله نحن
ضربت في البيت باعتبار في البيت نحن جوا
البيت ها وقمنا جارين لجوه باعتبار محل
الغزيف والحاجات
نتعرف ايضا على اهل المنطقه الذين هم في
هذه المنطقه يعني بالنسبه للسكان الذي
تضررت منازلهم بماذا يفكرون وبماذا يخططون
والله طبعا هما الناس ما عندها حاجه
تعملها
قاعدين هنا وفي امانه الله قاعدين الضربه
دي
رب العالمين ربنا يعيننا بس
رخيصه
ابونا في هذه البيوت بهذه الشاكله ام انكم
تخططون لترميمها او للخروج منها والله
طبعا ما عندنا حاجه نقدر نعمل نقدر نعمرها
نقعد بس
الذعر التمسناه من سكان هذه المنطقه
يقولون انهم ليس لهم علاقه بما يجري وما
يحصل ويتمنون ان تتوقف هذه الحرب السريعا
حتى يعيش المواطنون باطمئنان وامان وسلام
تمديد الهدنه والمعارك ياتيان وسط الحديث
عن مبادره الايجاد التي طرحت يوم امس حيث
قبلت بضبابيه ردود الاطراف بشان الجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات فقد قلت وزاره
الخارجيه السودانيه في بيان لها انه لا
صحه لدخول القوات المسلحه في تفوض مع قوه
دعم السريع واضافت الخارجيه السودانيه انه
لا خيار امام قوات الدعم السريع سوى
الاستسلام او الفناء بحسب تعبير البيان
وكان الجيش السوداني قد ذكر في وقت سابق
امس ان قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
وافق بشكل مبدئي على مبادره من منظمه
الايجاد تضمنت مقترحات لحل الازمه الحاليه
وحسب بيان الجيش السوداني فان المقترحات
تتضمن تمديد الهدنه اثنتين 72 ساعه اضافيه
كما تشمل المبادره افاده ممثلين عن القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع الى جوبا
للتفاوض
في المقابل قال يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع ان القوات ترحب
بكل المبادرات وهي ليست من دعاه الحرب
لكنها تحتاج الى مبادره حقيقيه حسب قوله
نحن نرحب بكل المبادرات نرحب بوقت الحرب
ولكن
التعامل مبادره حقيقيه محتاجين للتعامل مع
طرف حقيقي يستطيع
هذه خيارات ندرسها وفي الاخر كما ذكرت لك
تتوقف بالتفاوض
هذا معروف في كل الحروب هل البرهان يستطيع
ومن خلال الهودنات الاربعه التي مرت هل هو
قادر على ايقاف الحرب هذا ما لا نراه في
ارض الواقع نحن نرى
بيانات بوقف الهدنه بوقف الحرب ونرى في
ذات الوقت طائرات تقوم تضرب معكراتنا على
الجيش قرار الجيش في هذا البرهان هذا هذا
نشك فيه نشك ان البرهان يسيطر على الجيش
الان
هنالك من يحرك الجيش يحرك الطائرات اذا
كان هو لديه اثبت خلال الهدمات السابقه
انه يستطيع اتخاذ غرار الاضافه الحرب كما
اتخذ غرار الحرب يمكن التعامل مع هذه
المساله تتاكدها الايام القادمه
مدير معهد اون الدولي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك دكتور حسن
هل الوقت اليوم مناسب
لمبادرات من اجل حل الوضع في السودان
سياسيا ووقت الاقتتال
نعم اعتقد
التي هذه المقترحات والظروف توفر فرصه
للحوار لكن يجب ان يتم السماح لنشاط
الانساني بالاعتماد على ما تقوم به الدول
الاقليميه والمجتمع الدولي واذا ما كان
سيكون هذا الجهد كافيا ام لا نعم ولكن
سؤالي الظروف السياسيه الان المحيطه
بالوضع السوداني
والوضع الميداني ومواقف الاطراف
المتشنجه والتي مازالت تراهن بشكل كبير
على الحسم العسكري هل في في ظل كل هذه
الظروف هناك مبادره يمكن ان تنجح
ان ايجاد كونها منظمه اقليميه تقوم باداره
الصراعات هي
تعتبر ان هنالك لديها اراده طيبه للتدخلي
في الصراع لكن مع ذلك ايجاد ليس لديها اي
طريقه لاجبار الاطراف للتمسكي باي اتفاق
قدمتم التوصل عليه هذا الامر سيتطلب
المزيد من التحرك الدولي اذا ما كانت هذه
المبادره لتنجح الايجاد ليست لديها هذه
الوسائل لكن الولايات المتحده لديها وسائل
للضغط هذا ما تقوله واشنطن لديها امكانيه
للضغط على الاطراف والتاثير عليهم مثلا
كالعقوبات هل يمكن ان تصل الامور الى هذا
الحد بان تضغط الولايات المتحده من هذا
الباب
من باب العقوبات على الاطراف السودانيه
الاخذ بنظره الاعتبار التاريخ وخاصه
التدخل الغربي في
القاره قد لا تكون العقوبات هي طريقه
المثلى للتدخل في هذا الصراع والاتياني
بنتائج مثمره اعتقد ان من المهم ان نتذكر
ان
كلا من قوات الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
هنالك تقطع في الصوت هم يتلقون بعض الدعم
من الخارجي بالتالي
فان فرض العقوبات قد يزيد من سوء المشكله
ويزيد من تاجج الحرب الاهليه الدائره اذا
ما هو الافق الذي تراه لهذه الازمه
سالتك يعني اذا كانت العقوبات ربما
تؤدي الى تعقيد الوضع والاطراف الداخليه
لديها دعم
خارجي وايضا الايجاد ليست لدي قدره على
تاثير اذا يصبح السؤال ما هو الافق لهذه
الحرب كيف ستنتهي هذه الحرب برايك
احد الاشياء الذي يجب المهمه التي يجب ان
نتذكرها هو ان يتم السماح لهدنه لكي نسمح
بتحقق الحوار الايجاد قد لا تمتلك كل
الادوات لكنها اعتقد ان هنالك حاجه الى
دعم من الاتحاد الافريقي ومن اطراف اخرى
اذا ما فشلت القوى الاقليميه في حل هذا
الصراع قد يؤدي الامر الى انهيار الدوله
في السودان والى ازمه هجره ضخمه لم نراها
خلال سنوات
الدكتور حسن كاننجي مدير مع دورن الدوليه
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه من نيروبي شكرا
جزيلا لك
في داعيه الانسانيه قالت الامم المتحده ان
تقديراتها تشير الى احتمال فرار اكثر من
200 الف من السودانيين الى دول الجوار
بسبب استمرار القتال بين الجيش وقوه الدعم
السريع
مع استمرار القتال تستعد الامم المتحده
لتدفق اللاجئين الى البلدان في جميع انحاء
المنطقه بما في ذلك جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى وتشاد ومصر واثيوبيا وجنوب السودان
تقدر المفوضيه ان نحو 270 الف شخص يمكنهم
الفرار الى جنوب السودان وتشاد تناشد
المفوضيه الثانيه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين جميع البلدان المجاوره للسودان
ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه للاشخاص الباحثين عن
الاماني والحمايه
بين خيارات احلاها مر تجد ملايين الاسر
السودانيه نفسها في ظل استمرار المواجهات
المسلحه لليوم الثالث عشر فاما المخاطره
بالبقاء في منازلها رغم ما قد يجر ذلك من
امكانيه التعرض للقذائف والرصاص القادم من
طرفي الصراع فضلا عن تزايد صعوبه تامين
الاحتياجات الاساسيه من الغذاء والماء
والدواء او المخاطره برحله نزوح نحو مناطق
اخرى امنه داخل البلاد او اتخاذ قرار
اللجوء الى دول الجوار
وفيما يتعلق بمسارات النزوح فان العاصمه
الخرطوم لا تزال تشهد موجات نزوح يوميه
باتجاه الشرق والشمال وصولا الى مدينه
بورتسودان والحدود مع مصر كما شهدت مدينه
نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور نزوحا
داخليا لنحو 30 الف شخص وفق منظمه الهجره
الدوليه اما ولايه شمال كردفان نزوح
ثمانيه الاف شخص مع اندلاع المواجهات
ولايه شمال دارفور شهدت بدورها نزوحا
داخليا باتجاه مناطق امنه قدرتها منظمه
الهجره الدوليه باكثر من 16 الف شخص وعلى
ما يبدو فان التكثيف عمليات اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب في السودان قد حفز تسارع حركه
لجوء السودانيين الى دول الجوار وسط
مناشده من المفوضيه الساميه لشؤون
اللاجئين لتلك الدول ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه
للاشخاص الباحثين عن الاماني والحمايه
مسارات حركه اللجوء بدت على النحو التالي
من ولايتي كسلاوي الجضارف في الجنوب
الشرقي للسودان باتجاه كل من ارتريا
واثيوبيا من ولايتين للابيض وشرق دارفور
جنوبي البلاد الى دوله جنوب السودان التي
يقدر بان نحو عشره الاف سوداني قد لجاوا
اليها حتى الان من ولايه جنوب دارفور
باتجاه جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى من ولايتي
شمال وغرب دارفور باتجاه الجاره تشاد التي
يقدر بان نحو 30 الف سوداني قد لجاوا
اليها حتى الان رغم ان مفوضيه اللاجئين
تقدر بان الارقام قد ترتفع بشكل كبير جدا
فالتوقعات بان يفر نحو 270 الف سوداني الى
دوله جنوب السودان وتشاد وحدهما في حال
استمرار المعارك
في المجلس النرويجي للاجئين مرحبا بك سيد
ويليام
[موسيقى]
هل هذه التقديرات دقيقه فعلا وهل اللجوء
السوداني الى خارج السودان
متى يشكل ازمه بالفعل على دول الجوار
شكرا على
الاستضافه سيد حسن الجامود لقد تحدثت مع
كادري في مكون من 300 شخص في البلد وفي
المنطقه الوضع في السودان صعب للغايه
وكارثي هذه ارقام
اقل من الواقع وهنالك ايضا امكانيات
محدوده للمنظمات الانسانيه في السودان
لتقديم المساعده الكثير من وكالات الامم
المتحده قد تركت البلد بالتالي هذه هي فقط
قمه
جبل الجليد مثلا في الخرطوم التي تعرضت
للقصف هي مدينه يسكنها سبع ملايين شخص في
السابق للتالي قد يكون هنالك مئات من
الالاف او ربما لم يكن الملايين الذين
يحاولون ان يبحثوا عن لجوء خارج السودان
ولكن يعني عندما تتحدث عن ان تلك المنظمات
قد خرجت من السودان او على الاقل علقت
اعمالها بسبب
القصف لكن اللجوء الى خارج السودان الا
يفترض ان تكون هذه المنظمات موجوده في
اماكن اللجوء يعني في دول الجوار وليس
داخل السودان لمساعدتهم
اكيد هذه
اصبحت ربما اصبحت مناشده لجوء
اقليميه والكثير من الدول اظهرت عاطفا
ملحوظا وترحيبا للناس اللاجئين لكن قد
يصعب على الكثير من الاشخاص المغادره بعض
تلك الدول دول الجدار هي تعاني من ظروف
اقتصاديه صعبه بالتالي سيكون هنالك صعوبات
مترتبه عليهم وهنالك ضروره ملحه من
المجتمع الدولي ان يكون هنالك دعم لتلك
الدول للاجئين ايضا علينا ايضا ان نتذكر
ان السودان قد استضافت اكثر من مليون شخص
من تلك الدول في مراحل مقتبل الكثير منه
في الخرطوم ايضا بالتالي الوضع الاقليمي
صعب للغايه وهو يتشكل امامنا ونحتاجه الى
دعم حكومي من عده حكومات
اين هي الدول الاكثر او ما هي الدول
الاكثر تاثرا بازمه اللجوء بحسب
متابعاتكم لهذا الموضوع
لقد راينا تحركا عبر الحدود الى تشاد والى
جنوب السودان والى اثيوبيا ايضا وربما قد
يكون
هنالك ايضا
مجلس السوداني المصري كان هنالك الكثير من
الهجره المتبادله بين البلدين اي ضرر الان
الكثير من الاشخاص ينتظرون
يتوجهون الى الشمال وايضا يتجهون الى
المناطق الحدوديه بالتالي
من يهرب يجب ان يتم معاملتهم كلاجئين ويتم
منحهم حق اللجوء وكل الامور المترتبه عليه
الكثير من الاشخاص مع ذلك لم يتمكنوا من
تركي منازلهم لحد الان بالتالي نحتاجه الى
اجراءات وخطوات مهمه ليس فقط في داخل
البلاد لكن اقليميا ايضا مدير المكتب
السودان في المجلس النرويجي للاجئين
ويليام شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي مشهد اخر للمعاناه الانسانيه قال
المدير الاقليمي للاعلام في اليونيسف عمار
عمار للجزيره ان من الضروري توجيه مساعدات
دوليه عاجله للسودان بدوره داع صليبه
الاحمر والدوليه اطراف النزاع الى ضمان
سلامه وامن العاملين في المنظمات
الانسانيه كي يتمكنوا من القيام بدورهم في
ايصال المساعدات
ثلاثيه الصراع الدم والمرض والجوع في
السودان كم من روح ستزهق حتى ينجلي ليل
ماسي هذا البلد
الانتظار الطويل جدا والمر من اجل شراء
الخبز من رفاهيه ساعه الهدنه الهشه والمحل
النادره التي ما تزال مفتوحه في الخرطوم
تمت احياء اختفى فيها الخبز والماء
والكهرباء تماما السودان الكبير بمساحته
وتاريخه داخل اتون حرب عبثيه وعلى شفير
مجاعه كبرى وكارثه انسانيه ماضيه لدول
الجوار يقول المواطنون ان الازمه المعيشيه
بدات منذ اليوم الاول للاقتتال المفتوح
على اسوا السيناريوهات والنهايات باللغه
الارقام الاوليه المجاعه ليست شبحا بل
حقيقه موجعه يتجرعها الشعب في الخرطوم
ودارفور والولايات التي هرب اليها الالاف
بحثا عن الامان مثل الجزيره للازرق وشمال
كوردوفان ثمانون في المئه من الاسواق في
الخرطوم اغلقت خشيه اعمال النهب ارتفعت
اسعار السلع الاساسيه ما بين
3400 في المئه في بعض الاحيان الرفوف
الفارغه في المحل ستبقى كذلك الى اشعار
اخر تعطلت المصانع وتوقفت حركه الاستيراد
برا وبحرا وجوا تجار الازمات يعيشون عزهم
على ماس الاخرين الجسور المغلقه قطعت طرق
الامداد الى الخرطوم التي تعاني نقصا حادا
في كل شيء مع الرصاص ما في ما في موارد ما
في موارد ما في اي حاجه بضاعه جديده خالصه
ما في دقيق بيجي ما في حاجه ولا اي شيء اي
حاجه قطعت ثاني ما بتكون فيه
اعتراف الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيريش كل التقارير القادمه من
السودان ترسم صوره قادمه لعالقنا داخل
المنازل ونقص في امدادات الغذاء والماء
والادويه يستمر النجاح في عمليات اجلاء
الاجانب من السودان ومعه فشل المجتمع
الدولي في ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
بلد كان في زمن السلام يعتمد ثلث سكانه
على معاناه منظمه الاغذيه العالميه هذه
الصور بصت في مايو العام الماضي بمناسبه
تحذير الامم المتحده من مجاعه تهدد
السودان
كيف سيكون الوضع الان بعد انعدام الامن
لدرجه اغلاق السفارات واخلاق البلد من كل
اجنبي يمكنه النجاه من هذا الجحيم ماذا عن
السودانيين القطاع الصحي ليس بخير ووضعه
حرج للغايه كثره التحذيرات من المنظمات
العالميه وتعذرت الحلول لانعاش ما بقي من
مؤسسات طبيه تفيد منظمه الصحه العالميه ان
اكثر من 60% من المنشات الصحيه في الخرطوم
مغلقه وبان 16% فقط تعمل بشكل طبيعي علاج
ما يقدر بنحو 50 الف طفل يعانون سوء
التغذيه غير متاح بسبب دوامه العنف
الحاليه من يحرم السودانيين من امنهم
السياسي والغذائي والصحي من سرق مرحله كان
يفترض ان تنقله الى المدنيه التي صار من
اجلها قبل السنوات توقع كل شيء ما عدا ان
يستيقظ على حرب تندلع في الخرطوم وتمتد
السنتها الحارقه الى دارفور وغيرها من
المناطق حرب تقتل وتجوع وتهجر وتدمر سدانا
ليس به مكان لكل هذا الوجع
مشاهدينا وردت قبل قليل صور من بورتسودان
للمئات من رعايه الدول
الذين تمكنوا من الخروج من الخرطوم باتجاه
بورد السودان وهناك ينتظرون
اجلائهم او على الاقل ربما فرص اجلائهم من
هناك عبر البحر هذه ازمه جديده ايضا من
تداعيات هذه الحرب من الخرطوم معنى
المتحدث باسم اللجنه الدوديه لصليب الاحمر
في السودان سيد جيرمن بدوركم انتم كيف
تراقبون
تداعيات هذه الحرب على الوضع الانساني
والاغاف في السودان وانتم من داخل الخرطوم
الوضع
يبدو وكانه بدايه ازمه نتيجه للتقاتل في
الخرطومه في مناطق اخرى في السودان من
الاجانب الانساني الوضع يزداد صعوبه لقد
راينا اشخاصا يتركون الخرطوم ومدن اخرى
ويتجهون الى اماكن
يعتبرونها اكثر امنا هذه هذه هذا نزوح
نزوح داخل البلاد داخل السودان من مدينه
الى مدينه اخرى
من الخرطوم وايضا
في منطقه دارفور لانه ايضا هنالك قتال
مستمر في المدن
مثل الجنينه
وانيلا في منطقه دارفور بالتالي هناك كثير
الالاف في حقيقه الامر
نزحوا داخل السودان وفي نفس الوقت هنالك
ايضا اشخاص يغادرون السودان
يتركونها الى مناطق بلدان الجوار وخاصه
الى اثيوبيا والى مصر
والى تشاد
والى جنوب السودان بالتالي
الازمه تتخذ مجالا اقليميا لا يؤثر الامر
على السوداني فقط لكن
يؤثر على الدول المحيطه بالسودان هي تلك
الدول تتاثر بهذه الازمه الكبيره طب ما هي
امكانيات الصليب الاحمر الدولي في السودان
في نطاق عمله في نطاق عمله الانساني
والاغاث في الكثير من الاحيان مع استمرار
المعارك
ان
[موسيقى]
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر وبالتعاوني
مع جمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني نقوم
بتقييم الوضع في المدن المختلفه وحسب
تقييمنا المبدئي فان الحاجه الفوريه
المتمثله اليوم هي بتوفير الادويه والدعم
الصحيه للمستشفيات التي تعتني بالمصابين
والجرحى هذه هي الحاجه الانسانيه الفوريه
الاولى الحاجه الثانيه متمثله بتوفير مياه
الشرب والطاقه الكهربائيه للناس الذين
يعيشون في الخرطوم وفي المدن الاخرى
والذين تاثروا بالقتال
وبضمني هم توفير الكهرباء
للمستشفيات اذ ان معظم المستشفيات لا
تمتلك مياها صالحه
وطاقه كهربائيه بالتالي علينا ان نضمن ان
هنالك توفر للماء والكهرباء بالتالي هنالك
حاجه لصيانه هذه المنشات ومن المهم على
على الاطراف
المتصارعه ان تسهل عمل ليس فقط عمل
المنظمات الانسانيه لكن تسهيل عمل من يعمل
الان
في
منشات المياه والكهرباء
وتوفير
الصيانه
والجهد الضروري لاستمرار باستمرار توفير
هذه الخدمات
شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم
المتحدث باسم اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر في السودان جيرمن
ونتابع في الحديث واستطلاع الموقف بشان
الاوضاع الانسانيه معنى من القاهره
الدكتوره عبير عطيفه المتحدثه باسم برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
الدكتوره يعني سؤال المطروح هو الوضع
الايغاثي الوضع
الغذائي
لهؤلاء كانوا نازحين او حتى لاجئين او
اولئك الذين بقوا في الخرطوم ولكن نتيجه
المعارك تقطعت بهم السبل ولم
يجدوا حتى
مؤونه ايامهم القادمه
الاوضاع الانسانيه في
الخرطوم وفي معظم انحاء السودان اوضاع
صعبه
سلاسل الامداد والتموين فيما يخص بالمواد
الغذائيه والوقود طبعا تعطلت في الايام
الاخيره هناك شرح طبعا في الكثير من
المواد في المحل التجاريه وارتفاع اسعار
المواد بصوره يعني غير مسبوقه بسبب هذا
الشح
القطاع التجاري متوقف طبعا لخطوره الاوضاع
الامنيه طبعا على المجال الانساني عمليات
الانسانيه والتوزيع المواد الغذائيه متوقف
منذ منتصف هذا الشهر وبدايه يعني عدم
الاستقرار السياسي
والصراع المسلح الذي بدا وبسبب ايضا طبعا
برنامج الاجزاء العالمي بسبب بعد مقتل
ثلاثه من موظفيه في شمال دارفور في منتصف
هذا الشهر علق عمليه
الانسانيه والاغاثيه في داخل السودان حتى
يكون هناك استقرار نسبي في الاوضاع
الامنيه
في عمليه طبعا سلب ونهب
للمخابن والمستودعات التي الموجود بها
المساعدات الاغاثيه والانسانيه كل هذه
الظروف طبعا تكفع بالوضع الانساني في
السودان في مرحله بالفعل دخلنا في الدائره
الخطر يعني هناك الحياه الصعبه التي
يعيشها المواطن السوداني في ظل هذا الصراع
المسلح وان نجوا هؤلاء من هذه
يعني المناوشات في الشارع والصراعات
المسلحه الازمه الاكبر هي الحصول على
الغذاء
والوقود والماء والدواء
ليست ما قلتيه بان سلاسل الامداد قد تعطلت
ولكن يعني عبر البر وعبر البحر
لا يمكن ايصال هذه المساعدات لمستحقيها من
خلال تلك المعابر نفس المعابر التي يخرج
من السودانيون
ورعاية الدول الى الخارج اكانوا لاجئين او
حتى رعايه دول
يفرون من الحرب نفس هذه المعابر يمكن
ادخال تلك المساعدات لو توفرت الاراده الى
السودان اليس كذلك
بالنسبه للمساعدات الانسانيه والغذائيه
بالفعل لدينا في داخل السودان
مواد غذائيه تكفي لتقديم مساعدات الى
الكثير من الناس حتى قبل هذه الازمه
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي بيعمل في داخل
السودان لتقديم المساعدات الغذائيه لسبعه
ونصف مليون شخص بصوره شهريه
المشكله كيف يعني يتم التوزيع بصوره امنه
وبدون اي نوع يعني في ظل هذه الاوضاع
المترديه بدون ضمانات بدون هدنه بدون وقف
لاطلاق النار يصمد على المجال يعني على كل
المجالات وبالتالي يعني نحن يعني بنشهد
مشكله كبيره وهي ليست فقط في ادخال هذه
المساعدات الى داخل السودان لكن هي
توزيعها على المستفيدين بالنسبه للمجال
التجاري طبعا يعني شركات التامين كل هذه
ال ال يعني هناك معطيات اخرى للمجال
التجاري واعتقد يعني القطاع الخاص يعني
عنده مشاكل اكبر في ادخال المساعدات في
هذه الاوقات الصعبه
شكرا لك دكتور عبير عطيفه المتحدثه باسم
برنامج الاذيه العالميه لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا من القاهره
في اخبارنا الاخرى قتلت قوه الاحتلال شابا
فلسطينيا قرب سلفيت شماليه الضفه الغربيه
بزعم محاولاته تنفيذ عمليه طعن وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي في بيان ان تقارير وردت عن
محاوله دهس في المكان وان الشاب حاول
تنفيذ عمليه طعن قبل اطلاق النار عليه ولم
تقع اصابات في صفوف جنود الاحتلال
تظاهر الاف من انصار اليمين الاسرائيلي
امام المحكمه العليا في القدس الغربيه
دعما لخطه حكومه بنيامين اجراء تغيير شامل
على الجهاز القضائي في اسرائيل ورفع
المتظاهرون شعارات ترفض التسويه مع
المعارضه وتحث الحكومه على المضي في اقرار
خطتها وتاتي هذه المظاهره ردا على مظاهرات
مؤيدين معارضه الذين يعتبرون الخطه
انقلابا على نظام الحكم في اسرائيل
قلت البحريه الامريكيه ان ايران احتجزت
اليوم الخميس ناقله نفط ترثوا على ما جزر
مارشال في خليج عمان واشارت الى انها
سفينه التجاريه الخامسه على الاقل التي
تستولي عليها طهران خلال العامين الماضيين
وطلب بيان الاصول الامريكيه الخامس ايران
بالافراج عن الناقله فورا لافتا الى ان
تصرفات ايران تتعارض مع القانون الدولي من
جهه اكد الجيش الايراني احتجاز ناقله نفط
قال انها تنقل حموله امريكيه وترفع علم
جزر مارشال في خليج عمان واقل الجيش
الايراني ان الناقله اصطدمت بسفينه
ايرانيه في المياه الخليجيه وحاولت الفرار
عبر اطفاء اجهزه التتبع واشار الى اصابه
بحاره وفقدان اثر اثنين اثرى حادثه
الاصطدام
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان خلال
مراسم ضخ الوقود النووي لاول مره من روسيا
قال ان بلاده دخلت نادي دول الطاقه
النوويه في العالم بتدشين محطه اكويو
النوويه الجديده وفي اول ظهور له بعد وعكه
صحيه قال اردوغان ان المحطه ستوفر نحو 10%
من الطاقه التي تحتاجها البلاد وستكون من
اهم المشاريع التي لم تشكل عبئا على
الاقتصاد التركي
مشاهدينا مستمرون في هذه التغطيه للتطورات
في السودان
مدينه الجنينه تشتعل بالنيران
ضع في حي المدارس والجمارك وتجح مدارس
القديمه
وحس
النيران يعني شبت ما اعرف
اتجاهات كثيره
في السوق الجنوبي ويمكن يعني تسوق
الاجمالي زي ما شايفين
يعني تضررت بحجم كبير شديد وربنا بس يهون
في الجامعه الكبيره الضريبه الكبيره هناك
بحاجه بسيطه
[موسيقى]
والناس تتكافل مع اخوانه ممكن ناس تاكل في
بيوته والناس الميادين برا مسافرين
الشعب السوداني وربنا يسهل الامور يسهل
الامورنا
الله
اي حاجه نحن جاهزين
طبعا احنا مواطنين شندي ونحن يعني انا
واحد من الناس متطوع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه
للتطورات في